the sexual ideology that the libs are
promoting
ultimately is incoherent and you can see
this
you can see this especially
in a story from the new york post just
came out a few days ago
i'm in a relationship with my 1998 chevy
and our sex life is so special that is
the headline of it i think do we have
some b-roll of this
relationship yeah so it's
this is sort of i almost feel bad even
playing this it's a guy just kissing his
car and
and lying underneath his car and doing
all sorts of creepy things with his car
says uh he's 37 years old
he he came out
about 10 years ago as being in love with
his car
and all right that's enough beer i don't
need to see him kiss his car anymore
that's fine that's i'm sorry i asked i'm
sorry i asked it was my fault but i'm
sorry i asked he was on this show tlc's
my strange addiction
and it went viral at the time and now 10
years later he says i'm still i'm still
in love with my car i got a feel for my
automobile i like to lean over his
fender and across his hood and kind of
press up against him okay you get the
idea and he says that he does all the
sorts of things with this car
that
married people do with one another
the sexual revolutionaries are going to
laugh at this
they're going to say oh come on this is
what how dare you are you you're you're
comparing all of our kind of bizarre
sexual eccentricities like drag shows
for kids you're comparing it to this
wacko guy who's
got
objectophilia is the apparently the
medical term for it and he's in in love
with his car it's completely
incomparable
sure sure
now when when we conservatives have been
accused of suggesting a slippery slope
in years past uh it's taken about what
uh six months to at most five or six
years before we are at that point on the
slippery slope we get we get to that
slippery slope pretty pretty quickly but
actually the the guy in love with his
car poses a much bigger question for the
sexual revolutionaries than say
people warning about pedophilia
remember
during the sexual revolution there were
conservatives who are warning you know
if you normalize
certain errant and deviant sexual
behaviors pretty soon people are going
to try to normalize pedophilia and the
lib said that's not true that's
ridiculous that'll never happen and what
are they doing they're obviously
normalizing pedophilia right now you can
see it on tape
and you can hear them make the arguments
there was that professor who was fired
from uh from
old dominion college
for trying to normalize pedophilia and
then the the professor just got hired by
johns hopkins i believe
by a technically even more prestigious
university so they are normalizing this
but they'll say well uh look they might
if we normalize
deviant sexual behaviors
pretty soon some people will be trying
to normalize uh bestiality
and that's true that's been less common
than the people trying to normalize
pedos but you have seen pockets of that
but this is an even bigger this actually
is a bigger problem because
the sexual revolutionaries can say look
we support
the whole acronym and having you know
giant monkey pox orgies and you know
thrupples and quadruples and quintuples
and all they can say we support all that
stuff because it's all consensual
consent is the key here and a child
cannot consent now the libs are
weakening on this already they're saying
no a child not only can a child consent
to sex but a child can consent to
making permanent sexual decisions like
lopping off parts of his body so they're
already weakening on that but in theory
they could make that argument or they
could say look an animal cannot consent
this is why it's wrong to
to sleep with animals is if you you know
that you're violating their consent and
that's wrong but then my question is
what about the chevy
what about the 1998 chevy the 1998 chevy
doesn't have will doesn't have freedom
of choice it is not a conscious being to
my knowledge
just an old car
so if this guy wants to do all sorts of
creepy things and say love is love and
respect our love with his car
what's wrong with that
we all know
that this is extremely disordered and
wrong and should be discouraged and this
guy should seek help and not be
celebrated for
doing these sorts of things with his car
we all know that
but why
why conservatives can answer why
christians jews muslims people with a
traditional even somewhat traditional
religious sentence and moral sense can
tell you why because they'll say well
that
buddy
that body part of yours is not meant for
that muffler that that's not actually
men and women are complimentary and they
go together and they get married and
they create children and it's wrong and
you shouldn't do that thing that you're
doing underneath the car and that's just
intrinsically wrong and it's disordered
and it's contrary to the natural law
and they we can explain why it's wrong
but if you're only criterion for sexual
ethics is
if is consent
consent and if it feels good do it then
you can't say this is wrong and i bet
you if you talk to the real the real
radicals out there on the sexual
revolutionary side and you said hey what
do you think about the guy who's in a
relationship with his 98 chevy they
would say well you know if he likes it
whatever it's not hurting anybody who
cares
it's fine let him do it that's okay yeah
that's not my thing but that's fine
that is
that is a real divide
i
don't think that we as a society
should encourage that i don't think that
the guy this guy has any right to
[Music]
do those sorts of things with his car
i don't think that this is some sacred
natural i don't think love is love i
don't think
i don't think that
the the guy's relationship with his car
is something admirable that we should
encourage
and so
if we're if we're now at that position
where we're saying actually
some things are wrong then then and only
then can we crawl back to the like hey
maybe the kids should not be at the drag
show putting dollar bills in the g
strings of these weirdos
then and only then can we get back to
hey maybe you shouldn't be pumping
seven-year-olds full of
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
potentially
then and only then can we get back to
some semblance of hey hey maybe marriage
has a meaning
when we say marriage has a meaning by
the way we're not saying that we need we
should be really cruel to people who
have different sexual desires we should
be we should just beat these guys up we
should oppress them we should run them
out no one's saying that
we're saying that there is reality
that there is such a thing as marriage
and marriage has a meaning
no matter what the radicals want to
pretend the meaning is i can i can say
that this
leftist tears tumbler is a chainsaw and
i can even force everyone around me to
call it a chainsaw but it's not a
chainsaw because their reality has some
say here it's a leftist tears tumbler
and the point of it is to drink
delicious leftist tears
i'm glad you like that clip now ding
ring slam like
subscribe ping i don't uh whatever you
gotta do subscribe get the notifications
to the michael knowles show head on over
also to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe there leave a five
star review please we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you